Now let's do a final quiz here using again distance from triviality
so that you have a chance to understand this concept a bit better.
Let's consider 3-SAT this time.
You already know that 3-SAT is NP-complete,
and you 2-SAT is contained in P,
so 2-SAT is polynomial time solvable.
So let's consider 2 Boolean formulas here.
This is the first one here, x1 or not x2 or not x3
and x1 or not x5 or x6
and x2 or x5 or x7
and x3 or not x6 or not x7.
Now it's not really difficult to see if either of these 2 formulas
has a satisfying assignment or not,
and that's not really the point.
What I would like you to think about is the following:
Considering x1, x2, and x3,
which of these Boolean formulas is closer to triviality,
and by triviality I mean
which one of these is closer to a 2-SAT formula.
So look at x1, x2, and x3
and consider what would happen if you were to assign them true or false values.
And then you just check the appropriate box.